Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Welcome to another episode of Holistic Health Hour.
Remember, you can ask your questions ahead of time if you think you have some questions on our Holistic Health Hour.com website.
So, as you can see, all past episodes of our Holistic Health Hour on Holistic Health Hour.com website, they're nicely tabbed with the information.
So, it could be very beneficial with you're looking to get some questions answered.
Also, I recommend you go to our website, Cuttersplidic.com, where we have well over a thousand blog posts and also it's a different topics.
You might find your answers there, but let's jump right into the questions.
However, you can chat in your questions. Let me open up the chat here real quick and connect the chat.
So, if you do have questions, feel free to chat in any questions about any health conditions.
If I don't know the answer, I will say I don't know the answer.
Okay, so let's get started.
How do I treat a toddler with ear infections?
Also, how do I treat an infected small wound from a bird?
Okay, two questions. So, toddler with ear infections.
Well, historically, we used to try to educate parents because historically, people back in the 80s and 90s and early 2000s,
if their child would go in for pediatric well checks and the doctor would look at child's ear and whether the child had symptoms or not.
If you saw a full gene ear drum, they would say your child has an ear infection and they would write a prescription for antibiotics.
They'd literally give antibiotics like candy for ear infections.
Many times it's a child that was pulling out their ear and for complaining of ear pain,
parents would run to their pediatrician to get antibiotics for ear infections.
At least to argue, let's say, trying to educate parents at that time because statistically, it's well documented that over 90% of ear infections in children are viral.
Therefore, antibiotics are going to work.
So, antibiotics are only going to work on a bacterial infection.
Viral infections are not going to touch.
It's only going to do more damage than good so you don't use antibiotics.
Typically, you're not going to go to antibiotics for ear infections.
But I do realize that while most ear infections will pass over time with no treatment needed since its viral and viruses will run their course,
some kids are prone to constant ear infections and that can be an issue.
Many times it's because of just genetically the shape of their ear canal
and fluid tends to puddle in there and they can end up with external ear infections that can lead to infections of the drum.
Many times it can be some other underlighted cause giving the middle ear infections.
So, what do you do?
So, there are some natural things that you could do for external ear infections.
External means external to the drum and there's some natural things you could do for middle ear infections.
The external ear infection, there's garlic oil.
Herb farm makes a good garlic oil that you could drop, that you could put in a child's ear.
You could put hydrogen peroxide, 3% hydrogen peroxide in a child's ear to kill any external
ear infections. So, that would be also known as swimmer's ear. If it's in middle ear infection,
probably what this question is based on, then you want to treat the child as far as
building up their immune system to help them be able to deal with viruses. So, things like vitamin C,
zinc, echinacea, there's different liquid, herbal formulas that are created for children
that can help build their immune system and help them be able to fight off viral infections.
Getting adjusted, going to a car park or getting adjusted, their upper cervical
adjusted could be extremely helpful for children with their infections.
The second question, also, how do I treat an infected small wound from a bird? Well,
you know, that's a tough question to answer because it depends on how deep the bird is, what level
a bird it is. If you're trying to, if you have an infected wound, there's topical,
um, from a medical standpoint, there's obviously topical antibiotics, triple antibiotic
appointments with things. From a natural perspective, a person could use honey that could help
heal a wound and kill infection. A person could use topical hydrogen peroxide.
There's different topical treatments that are, if the wound is a closed wound, it's not open
anymore. You could use comfort if it's a closed, if it's a closed wound, you could use colledula.
There's, there's, um, other different appointments that a person could use on a wound.
If it's a bird that needs to be treated, if it's a third-degree bird or something like that,
you're going to end up going into the ER that you don't want to be putting that anything on it
until you get in there because they're going to scrape that off. But if you're, if that's not the case,
and it's a small bird, and it's just a rule that seems to be festering and open,
then you want to make sure that it doesn't get infected. So that's where, um,
topical antibiotic, hydrogen peroxide, or even honey can be helpful in those cases.
Next question, will your state-at-home care offer genetic closely for non-cancer folk?
So, our state-at-home care, um, so I, uh, so understand our clinic the way we operate is
everything is at a distance. We've done that for years. So we've done genetic closely at a distance
for gosh, probably 10 years. So, um, there's no need, there would be no need, there was never a need
to cover the office for closely to go over a person's DNA. So we always did that at a distance,
but we always have done genetic closely for non-cancer patients as well. So yes, you can
purchase our, um, that also comes with what was a course on what I created multiple lots and lots
of videos on the genetic pathways. Um, I'm sure I have a lot of them available outside of the course,
our blog post, and our videos website as well. But, um, the, I put those videos in a course to help
a person understand their genetics. So we use a company called DEA Separation to run genetics because
it gives you the broadest base of picture of genes. Um, this was a question I think last time
about genetics and using different, there's a lot of different genetic companies now. And
there's a lot of them that'll say, uh, here, it's $250 to get a genetic picture of for
or possible weight loss help or for possible food allergies or for possible, um, you know,
pick the condition. Um, I'm not in favor of those. Um, our genetic picture looks at all your genes
and then I, we give you that, um, whole, full genetic picture readout. So when you do genetics with us,
we give you the whole genetic picture readout, which is called a full genetic report. And it's about
350 pages. It's overwhelming. So we try to break it down. So then we give you what I, I go through
all of that and I'm the one who goes through it for a person and types out a genetic, um, summary.
So that's about 20 pages long. So we give you a genetic summary. So go ahead and look at your
full genetic report, you know, for fun and you really want to nerd out on all your genes. But then
look at your genetic summary because these are the genes that we need, you know, to be concerned with
that could be issues. That's still a lot of pages. And I also give you another report that's called
your genetic action steps. So it's really, you know, based upon everything that's going on, these
really should be your action steps in my opinion. And you get all that data with our genetic report.
I don't, the other reason why I don't like those genetic reports that say here, run this genetic report
for you're trying to lose weight. So tell you the genes that you need to support if you're,
if you're having issues with losing weight. There's a lot of, um, have truths with that.
So your genes cause issues. If you have defects in your BDR, your vitamin D receptor genes,
you're going to probably have issues, um, holding vitamin C, absorbing vitamin C,
utilizing vitamin, excuse me, vitamin D. And you, if you ran a vitamin D, um, blood test to see your
level of vitamin D, you'll notice that it's low, even if you're taking vitamin D. Well, if you look
at somebody's blood test and their vitamin D levels are low, it's a, and they don't have genetics
done on them. It's pretty good chance that they have defects in their BDR, their vitamin D receptor
genes. So knowing that you have defects in those genes, it might be a good idea to take extra
vitamin D. So there are action steps that a person could take looking at one's genes.
But you can't say, oh, I am obese because of my genes. Or can I say, I have constant infections
because of my vitamin D receptor genes. Well, there's factors that play into that.
Yeah, if you had a higher level of vitamin D, would you be able to fight off viral infections
more readily? Sure. So there's action steps that you can take based upon your genes,
but your genes don't make up your life per se. It's, it's much more of an epigenetic
factor that makes up your illnesses or lack their abs than it is your genes. But we do think it's
important to look at one's genes because looking at one's genes, it gives you ideas of things that you
can support. Let's say if I have a lot of defects in my phase one detoxification pathways in my liver,
then it's a good idea to support those. Maybe that's why I'm a slow detoxer. Maybe why I don't get rid
of things as fast as my wife does. And I end up with liver issues or possibly cancer issues. So
knowing your genetics can be beneficial, but it doesn't shape your whole life. So it's certainly
knowing your genetics is not going to say you have specific food allergies. But it says, hey,
if I have HLA gene defects, then I have a greater propensity to having allergies to gluten and
dairy and things like that. But that doesn't mean I do. So I think it's better to take a bigger look
at your genes. When I always say a 30,000 foot view of your genetics and look at all of them,
it's how they interplay it or act. And then treat the person, make suggestions on how to care for
the person based upon that. Make lifestyle suggestions based upon that. Another example,
I think ill advice, wrong advice around genetics has been for those who have some information on
genetics would be the methyl tetrahedral folate reductase genes, the MTHFR genes. Those are
some of the first genes that were recognized. And many times I'll have a patient come to us and say,
hey, I have a little defect on C677, MTHFR gene. So I have to take methyl groups and
talk about methyl folate and I'm on methyl comolabated. And I'm having all these issues. Well,
if a person only ran those, if a practitioner only recommended getting a genetic test that had those
in the mix and not some downstream genes in the mix, you could actually do more harm than good
to the patient. Because you could be overmethylating the patient. Because they have that MTHFR gene,
defect is think that they need more methyl groups. They're overmethylating them because you didn't
look at the big picture of their genes and they have defects in their biopterate pathway, which could
lead to emotional issues and serotonin issues and all sorts of problems. So long answer to this question,
but yes, we do genetic testing and yes, we do genetic counseling if you want to say that support
for people based upon their genetics. And yes, you know, doing it in a distance is really the way
to do it. But you want to get genetics done where you're going to see as many genes as possible so
you can see the whole mix of how they interact because your genes are simply ways that your body makes
proteins and makes hormones and makes things. That's what your genes do and we want to look at how
those all interact from a physiological standpoint. Hopefully that wasn't too long to answer the
matter. Hope for that. Next question. I've started taking HCl and Burberry for Hpylori. I was taking
one Burberry with my VLs three times a day, but I noticed that the Burberry was making me incredibly
fatigued. I took it away for a couple days and continued the HCl to confirm. Is it okay if I take
the Burberry all at once after my last meal of the day? How do you suggest I take someone take it
for a current Hpylori infection? So Burberry would be one of my favorite things to take for
an Hpylori infection. Burberry has other benefits as well. It's a great cancer killer
and it can help with other bacterial infections and even viral infections. I
it's one of my favorite supplements. I haven't had a lot of people that have said that Burberry makes
them sleepy, makes them fatigued. It quite possibly may be the die-off of Hpylori. So Hpylori is a
gram-negative bacteria. Gram-negative bacteria is, so you might have heard of gram-negative
bacteria when someone's referred to Lyme disease, too, Borrelia, Bergerdorphy. The bacteria
Lyme disease is a gram-negative bacteria. Gram-negative bacteria are called that because they stain
with the gram-stain, differently than gram-positive bacteria. The reason why they do is because they have
in their cell membrane, they have lipopolysaccharides, which is a long-chain saccharide
and that lipopolysaccharide will be liberated when they die. So if you know, for someone to get
the tea after taking Burberry, I don't think it's a function of the Burberry per se, but it's probably
a function that I'm just thinking this through. It's probably a function of the Burberry
or it could be two things. It could be a function of the Burberry actually killing Hpylori and
liberating lipopolysaccharides and giving the person a hook-siber reaction. So a hook-siber reaction
is when you produce a lot of endotoxins and most commonly, it's through the death, the killing,
the lysis of gram-negative bacteria spilling tons of lipopolysaccharides into your bloodstream,
and then your liver has to get rid of it. So your liver is overwhelmed, getting rid of
endotoxins, in this case lipopolysaccharides, it can make you feel, it can make you feel
ill, almost foolish, just really tired. That's what's called a hook-siber reaction. It's been
defined as a hook-siber reaction, and lying people will often say that they got a hook's reaction.
But that could happen whenever you're killing especially gram-negative bacteria.
So that could be a possibility that you're actually killing the Hpylori, which is a good thing.
So certainly, yes, you could change when you take it, you could take it all in the evening,
you can play with that dosage. It's not necessary that you need to be killing that bacteria,
you know, 24-7. So certainly, you can play with it. The other possibility is that Burberry does have
other physiological functions in your body, it could lower your blood sugar. So if the Burberry
is, in fact, lower your blood sugar, causing you to have fatigue because you have hypoglycemia,
that's a whole other ball of wax. So if you have a glucometer, it would be a good idea to check your
blood sugar levels. You don't want your blood sugar levels to drop below 70. If they drop below 70,
75, what do you not try to keep your blood sugar low, like in the case of cancer patients? But
if they drop down below that level, you could have fatigue and exhaustion because of hypoglycemia.
So that's another possibility, easily measured normally after your blood sugar levels up,
but then it's supposed to go back down to normal, not dipping down to a hypoglycemic state.
So do check that as well. If you do have hypoglycemia from Burberry, it's quite possible that you have
a level of hypoglycemia without Burberry that you might not fully recognize or notice. So having a
glucometer to check your blood glucose levels would be a good idea to be able to diagnose hypoglycemia.
Then the treatment for hypoglycemia really is going to be to not eat three meals a day,
but to break that up at the maybe six meals a day and have food in front of you all the time so
that you can keep your blood sugar regulated. And where would you get a blood sugar checker
and glucometer? Well, you can just get that a target. I can prick your finger, check your blood sugar.
Pretty simple to do. Next question, how do you fight endometrial lung cancer? So
maybe this person asked this question last time a little different way, but I think you're asking
lung cancer, endometrial cancer that has metastasized to the lung because the endometrial is
a distance away from the lung. Coming from endometrial cancer that was removed in 2012 from the
total misdirectomy, do you fight it with hormone therapy or chemo or what? You know, that's
not a question I could just answer real simply on a list of health hours here. So you'd need to
work with either our clinic or a clinic that's going to treat you as far as looking at your whole
picture. So if you have endometrial cancer that was treated in 2012 and now it's metastasized to the
lung and how would you know that? Because if you have lung issues and they see a mask, they do a
biopsy and it's actually endometrial cancer in the lung. So lots of times people will realize that
when you have metastasis of a cancer to another spot in the body, it's still that same cancer.
So how would we treat that? Again, we don't treat cancer but we treat the person and how would we
care for somebody with metastatic cancer is we certainly use right technology and we'd use
nutrition or diet and work along with your oncologist if you're going to be working with an oncologist.
Can you use hormone therapy? Well, if it was estrogen receptor positive or progesterone
receptor positive or two positive in the first place and they did another biopsy of this one,
they should be checking whether it's hormone positive or negative with this one because just because
it was with the first one, it does not mean it is with this one. So hormone therapy might have no
effect on it. Would you use chemo or what possibly totally depends on the person, depends on what's
going on. I just can't answer that and I'm not a practitioner that is completely against chemo but I
think you should be doing other things as well. Okay, there's a very long question. I have
bursitis in both legs, fibrobiology and Hashimoto's. I now eat a plant-based cold food diet. It's been
a great process of education and experience. Five years ago, I did a new I did a new physical therapy
exercise that flared both hips so bad that the left leg and hip. Down is still overreacting.
It put me into the worst fibrobiology player I have ever had. I was flair-free for close to a year
at that point and fortunately, I had to do corner zone injections and a relative predisode to
calm down the inflammation. I can finally walk with assistant devices and slowly have been able to
walk a block or so. I recently have had my left side start to seize up again with stretches. I have
to be very careful. I am an over-stretcher. Gentile yoga, dry needle aid and cupping massage seem
to help but then it's like the hip muscles are left, leg muscles grab and go let up. Is there anything
you can do that would help? I have learned by my feedback techniques to release muscle tension but it
doesn't help much after walking activity. I don't know if I don't know who asked these questions but
I don't know if you have enjoyed our product disease and autoimmune course. If you go to our website
cutters clinic.com you'll see up at the top. I have courses so I've created courses for people to
try to help them get educated and how to self-care because I believe we're moving into a time where
you have you you have to take responsibility for your health. This person was obviously doing that
and asking good questions but you'll find in with an autoimmune disease so let's talk about that.
Versitis and both hips. Versitis and both hips could be you know just from a local injury right?
You could have inflammation because of the local injury. You could also have
versitis and joint issues that are from systemic inflammation. So in the systemic inflammation we
can be due to an autoimmune player. Now person has fibromyalgia. What's fibromyalgia?
Fibromyalgia is just a collection of symptoms. It's not a disease in itself. It's coming from
something. So many times people with fibromyalgia actually have antibodies, self antibodies to their
muscle tissue and or their biology cells in the brain and or their fibers in the muscles that cause
contraction and or our arthritis, our thoracic antibodies and or rheumatoid antibodies it just
goes on and on. So fibromyalgia is caused from something we'd want to find out what antibodies this
person has. Hashimoto's is antibodies to either thyroid globulin antibodies or TPO antibodies.
That's to your thyroid globulin. So first case first step as far as if I was going to
manage this case we'd want to get a xy-rex array five and maybe even a xy-rex array seven x panel
on this person those are blood tests to find out what antibodies you have
so that we know what we're dealing with. That's going to be more diagnostic to give us okay this is
what is going on. That as far as how to treat it is that when you have self antibodies. So we
already know this person you already know you have a diagnosis of Hashimoto's. You already know you
have TPO antibodies or thyroid globulin antibodies. So we have antibodies to the thyroid. So whenever you
have a diagnosis of autoimmune disease and KAA antibodies to any self tissue whatsoever
there's anything can flare it from physical activity that's too great with physical injury
which can increase cytokine activity which is inflammatory and that's can flare up the autoimmune
disease and just cause this giant snowball effect flare to exposure to toxin or a mold or a
food that you have antibody against them. These are things that cause flares. So you alluded to that
term flare. So from an autoimmune perspective we call it a trigger. So what is the trigger that's
causing the flare. That's what we need to identify. Whenever you're dealing with an autoimmune disease
you've got to find your triggers. I mean you're never going to win if you don't figure out your triggers
and they can change. So running a food panel which would be like a Syrex Array 10 food panel
looking at the gut issues that you might have which would be a Syrex Array 2. So Syrex has the
best antibody panels. That's why I keep using that lab's name in the answering this question. So
looking at the level of leaky gut that a person has. Do they have paracelular leaky gut? Do they
have trancellular leaky gut? Do they have lymphopolysaccharides? Antibodies to lymphopolysaccharides
which would be the worst level of leaky gut? Do they have antibodies? What are their self-tissured? Do
they have antibodies against? And then what foods do they have antibodies against? At least we know
we need to eliminate those triggers. And then do we need to run a microtoxin test or another you know
full toxin load test to see you know what exposure that you have to different things that could
be causing triggers. That could be a trigger that are causing flares. So that's how you need to
kind of figure this out. From an immediate standpoint as far as nutritive things that you want to do
be a good thing to get on like an autoimmune diet right off the back even before you're checking these
things to make sure that you're not taking any immune stimulants. This is probably the number one
thing that we see with people that maybe even know they have an autoimmune disease. They have
Hashimoto's and then they're taking vitamin C and garlic and echinacea and all these immune
stimulants on a regular daily basis. You can't do that. Bad alone is going to be a trigger. You can't
stimulate your immune system. What are you going to kill if you stimulate your immune system? You're
going to kill that what you have antibodies against first which is self-tissue. You're going to cause
these flares. So you've got to get off of all immune stimulants. And then you know as far as
supplementation, the things that a person should be on in general would be the flavonoids. They
have to anti-inflammatory nutrition like curcumin and oswellia, white willow bark and things that
are going to call the TH for the response. Rosemary, you know, corset and things like that. So
yeah, we have to kind of uncover the onion a little bit and see what layers that we're dealing with.
And I hope that helps. So whoever asks this question, if you have a practitioner that you're working
with, show them this video, if you don't have a practitioner, you can make an appointment with me.
Anybody listen to this. If you do want to make an appointment with me, you can just go to our
website colors clinic.com and you can self-schedule or you can call the office if you want you to
and discuss the possible ways to work with us. If you schedule with call the case review,
which is your initial consultation. We don't take everybody as members,
slash patients, but I think I can help you then we work to here then we can work together.
But I don't think I can help you. I think you could better serve locally than I'll tell you that too.
Hopefully I helped answer that question. This question was asked last time but our last video got
so muffled. I don't know what was wrong with our connection. So I'm going to answer it again.
A 17-year-old son pulled a tick off his stomach Tuesday morning. This is probably a month to go down.
And I'm not sure if he got the whole thing out. It was ran around the bite. Is it necessary to get
the whole thing out or will it work its way out? Now your body will heal if there's if you leave
anything in it like a sliver or a part of a bug. You know, bobskis have a bug.
But it's much better to get it out to care. If this tick is infected, if this tick does have
Borrelia, then it's more important to get that out because the infected part is probably going to be
the bobskis that's left in the tissue. So I'm sure this was already taken care of. But for anybody
we'll be forward and have this same question. You want to try to get it out. There are some little
tick dislodging tools that you can buy on the internet. We used to sell them in our store.
We have any more but you could just buy them on Amazon for your dogs or your cats or your
children or yourself. There's little hooks that go around the tick and your twists called tick
twisters or something like that. It pulls the tick off real nice. Good thing to have. But you know
just because the person who got a tick bite doesn't mean that they have Lyme disease or that tick
was infected. Even if that tick was infected, you have the possibility of your body killing onto
the bacteria and you never end up getting quote unquote Lyme disease because your body killed it.
That's what your body is supposed to do. Your immune system is supposed to kill
enemies that are trying to attack it. It's when your immune system is down or the infection is too
great that it becomes more of a problem that the person can end up setting up this product on.
If a person does think that they have an infection and they you know they might have evidence of that.
They might have an you know fever that might feel ill that I do think you know knowing that hey I've
got a tick got the tick off but you know I'm feeling ill or my child's feeling ill. They have evidence of
a fever. They don't feel well. I do think it's wise knowing how bad Borrelia could be and how bad
chronic Lyme could be to get it antibiotic. The typical antibiotics that would be used as
doxocycly and or a moxicillin I think it's wise to go all of that. Now the course of days depends on
the Lyme literate doctor that you're going to go to anywhere between 10 days and 30 days would be
the course of treatment. Is it always suggested to follow that course of treatment? You're going to
I legally can't answer that question so you're going to have to make some decisions.
Question came out of the chat. I had a significant reduction in the last month of the size of my
lip bales. I've been alternating. I've erected an appendisol with other recommended treatments coming
up on the last week of the appendisol treatment and asking if I should stick with appendisol or switch
back to Ivermectin for the next six weeks. So just understand I can't legally answer a question
regarding medication on this platform. We are live on Facebook and YouTube etc. So I have to be
careful of that. So this person should contact us so we can talk about that.
That medisol and Ivermectin have both got really good reports in the last couple of months with some
data that has come out for treatment of cancer and where doctors have been completed. In fact,
we had the FDA come after us. Gosh, what was I a year and a half ago? That made us take down all our
data on our website on appendisol. They said to be an 11. I can't remember how to page letter,
but it was like the right need to sue the cancer. If I did it, we didn't follow through immediately
but taking everything down. We had seven days or something to get everything, take it down,
but a crock. But that's the things that we deal with. So I apologize that I can be careful with any
advice on any medications put out to where other people would see them. YouTube is taking down
our videos almost on a weekly basis as well. Silly ones, two of them really could have picked
a little more controversial video to take down. Of course, it's just their AI that's picking stuff up.
But it's a little frustrating that they could have
photographic videos all over YouTube, but you can't have videos that tell people to take
mushrooms for their immune system. Okay, so next question that we had, so keep asking questions
in the positive case that's what's there. But yeah, in general, basically keep alternating or stick
with what's working. Obviously, you know, you want to stick with what's working. There isn't anything
wrong with what you're dealing with anything to pulse stuff. So pulsing nutrition and or what you
asked about here can be beneficial. Our body can get used to things. So going off of things for a
couple weeks or switching to something else for a period of time can be beneficial. So you can see
better results too. So don't feel bad about doing that. Next question that I got asked with time for
a few more. What's the best treatment for indigestion? Well, indigestion is a word that encompasses
a lot of symptoms. So the person has a lot of gas or a person gets constipation or a person has
diarrhea, a person has tummy aches after they eat, a person has birthing, gulching after they eat,
a person has heartburn. All these things can be called indigestion. So we'd want to know a little
bit more information. But in general, most got issues really start with an issue with most commonly
a decrease hydrochloric acid production of the stomach which leads to a lot of stress on the
pancreas in production of enzymes. So the basic general best recommendation for people with any
tummy issues whatsoever is to start taking some HCl with digestive enzymes. Now you can get a person
with such bad gut issues that they take HCl with digestive enzymes. You only take those with
your foods who take it with a meal. So a person will say I did that and it really just caused really
bad pain in my stomach. Well, then you got to kind of take a step back and treat the gut because you
probably have just a slight ulcer or some serious irritation. Maybe you have to go to use some
gut healing products like slippery elm. I'd have a whole protocol on this on our website.
If you go to our website cuttersclinic.com and you search hypochloridria. Hypo leads low
chloridria. Hypochloridria is low stomach acid. Okay, low hydrochloric acid in your stomach. So if you
search that I have a whole protocol and it kind of walks you through if you have really bad pain
then switch. Take go off of the HCl, try apple cider vinegar for a period of time. Still have pain
without them. Maybe try slippery elm. Well, it's a new product by Zellibogen. It's a really good
called GI suit. It's really beneficial. Little kids can take that. It's the chocolate favorite
flavored tablet that you can do suck on because you want to heal the tract all the way down
even the esophagus that will help heal the stomach and the esophagus. To a point where a few weeks
later then you could start taking apple cider vinegar with your fluid and you could tolerate that
and you're starting to do a little bit better and now you could take HCl at that distance.
Of course, there's also some other things that encompass the digestion from diarrhea and constipation
and again, the next thing that happens after HCl deficiency is what's called the gigacidral
or the gigacidral. There's really three levels of that. What you have, intestinal probability
and you can test for that. So that's the cyroxyrate, two tests. But short of that, just try to heal.
They got triedified and it sets food sensitivities trying to fight the things that are causing
players to try to settle that down because the way to go. Next question. My daughter gets anxiety,
especially around her cycle. What could be the cause? Well, any type of mood issues with
your children and obviously their cycles should must be 13, 14, 15 years old. You certainly think
any type of issues around the person's cycle, you think of hormonal issues. The most common
hormonal issues in young adults are just a decreased function of adrenal gland. Many times these
kids are fairly stressed with school and the pressures of school decrease function. Patuitary
gland, just gaining them on some adaptogens is the number one thing to look at. Adaptogenic herbs
are called adaptogens because they help you adapt to your environment and they do so they help balance
your thyroid and your pituitary and your adrenal glands and those are the glands that control,
you know, progesterone and estrogen output and can help with any issues with your cycles.
So that would be the first thing to start. Obviously getting tested, there's some adrenal stress tests
out there. There's hormone Dutch tests that also test the adrenal glands and look at that. Also,
genetic issues can be an issue that I mentioned earlier that a person that has a defects in their
genetic pathways called the biopter and pathways can be more prone to imbalances in neurotransmitters
and then certain dietary things can cause it in flux, can push that pathway too hard
and cause excess or deficiencies in dopamine or serotonin or other neurotransmitters as well.
And you want to look at that. All sorts of other issues that could cause mood disorders,
whether it be anxiety or depression or OCD or inability to handle stress. So we want to take
a deeper dive into that because that could be a very serious problem. So we want to feel that.
Question from the chat, my father is beginning to slip mentally with memory and cognitive function.
What would you recommend supplement wise? I've had research at a D. What is the best
if you had to pick one? Well, usually with early dementia, Alzheimer's, any type of memory loss,
you did just right across the board, there's inflammation in the brain. Now, you could have
argued with people what's causing that inflammation because the truth is a lot of things can cause that
inflammation. It's why very much it gets the flu vaccine or elderly, they push it so hard
elderly, elderly, has way too many micrograms of aluminum in it and it's the size of aluminum is,
you know, they say it's really small so you don't have to worry about it. Well, you have to worry
about it even more because it's really small. It easily crosses the blood brain barrier and it's the
source of inflammation. All the studies out there on Alzheimer's, a brain inflammation,
microgluial primate, antibodies to neural tissue, tie to infection and toxins, also possible
injury like post-concussive syndrome. So people that have had concussions through their life
are going to be much more prone to microgluial primate, which leads to, depending on where it is,
which can lead to dementia and loss of brain function or Parkinson's or a full-blown Alzheimer's disease.
So, I have a video on this on our website that's called Neural,
Neural inflammation and microgluial primate. So on the website, if you search Neural
inflammation, you'll see that. But it goes into depth about that and it goes into depth about
what supplements to use. In general, the supplements that you would want to use would be antenna
laboratories. So, would you take this person to try to do chelation therapy to pull out the
heavy metals of this person as heavy metal issues? Well, personally, I wouldn't do that unless we did
a full workup and figured out what could be the cause so we don't look really with. But in general,
you'd want to decrease the inflammation. So, the way you would decrease the inflammation is usually
flavonoids. What are flavonoids? There are supplements like curcumin,
I mentioned before, rosemary, corseted. But as well, we have a product that has a bunch of them.
It is called Clear Inflamm. There's another product called caparrests that has a bunch of them
in there. We use both of those a lot. But taking, you know, a bunch of flavonoids and getting
out of the antenna inflammatory diet is the key. Also, I'd say you've got, I don't know if you're
dancing a drinker, it'd be like cisbeer or it's hot, tidy at night. Alcohol is the worst, you know,
culprit with all the research on brain inflammation. He's got to get off alcohol. And then other
things that are common that can cause more inflammation, gluten is a key factor. Look at other food
sensitivities, but never what is getting them on flavonoids. I haven't taken a lot of flavonoids.
All right, well, that is all the time we have for today. I hope that helped. Remember to go to
Felistic Health Hour.com where you can see all our past episodes. And go to cottagecredic.com
where if you're so desire, you can make a play with me or you can just visit our blogs or you can go
enjoy one of our courses and you can get more of me than you really go. But it will help you walk
through a lot of things that you might be dealing with. So feel free to do that. I wish you the best.
Thanks so much. And I will talk to you soon. We'll talk back next week. We ever go to
Felistic Health Hour.com to ask questions as well. All right, that's all the best day.